alright hey everybody I'm backstage here
with dr. Martin Blaser there's Bill
Maher and you wrote this amazing book
missing microbes have the overuse of
antibiotics is fueling our modern
plagues and you talked a little bit a
little bit about the modern plague idea
with Bill and it's a scary idea like
could a plague happen to us today it is
scary
and I don't even like writing about it
but it's better to face possibility than
to just ignore it and bury our head in
the sand we live in a world that is
smaller we're only two days away from
any village in the world because of Jeff
point if somebody had something they
could bring it to Los Angeles or to New
York to Chicago and in fact that's what
happened with SARS about ten years right
and we were lucky with stars because it
didn't spread very much if something
could spread what is the and do you know
what Spectre why didn't stars because
stars SARS jumped from animals to humans
and it wasn't that efficient in units
but if we had something that really
transmitted well we really would be in
trouble is that just a fluke of nature
sort of thing these are flukes in nature
but they happen the problem is that our
defenses are probably depleted because
of antibiotics and
that are removing our diversity and
diversity is a defense against invaders
we know that on the cornfields we know
that in forests and we know that in
experiments with animals that the good
bacteria protect us against the bad
bacteria I've talked about cesarean
section right back with the rates are
just have been going up all over the
world and again it's something that's
life-saving in a small percentage of
women and babies that more and more and
more are being done because nobody
thinks there's any cause but now there
have been four studies that have shown
that babies born by c-section are more
likely to become obese when they're
teenagers
then then kids not formed by c-section
when you control it for all other
factors then you take no other factors
into account and the reason for that do
you think it's because when you're taken
out by a c-section you're not you don't
encounter the same sort of microbes that
do so when a baby's born
the usual right that's really the way
mammals have been born for the last
hundred million years all mammals
whether they're bears or elephants or
mice or people it's always through the
birth canal that's how nature intended
it and the baby is covered with the
Manas bacteria they swallow the moms
back to what a c-section that doesn't
happen and
there's evidence that that early
microbiome is a little different in the
vaginally born baby in a c-section baby
we think that that's what's contributing
is there any way that you can like
recreate that micro by a little baptism
but so so you're in missing microbes yes
I discussed the work of my wife who is
doing just those experiments oh she's
studying three groups of mothers vaginal
delivery c-section delivery and then
c-section delivery where they put a swab
in the vagina and now they swab the baby
born by c-section to restore what's
happened she ready has presented work at
a meeting that she's getting partial
restoration
so that could be into one way the birds
yeah I tell her she's not a doctor I'm a
doctor I tell her you're gonna change
medicine you're doing amazing work thank
you so much for coming on the show
tonight you're great go missing microbes
and it'll freak you out a little bit but
it's good for you because you need to
know this stuff
I haven't even washed my hands since I
read this a couple weeks ago so we got
the micro biomes are mixing